I will tell you what I do like the
format of prospects versus veterans that
I actually I think they nailed that oh
you and I again disagree on this the
chance of a veteran winning the show is
pretty high if that veteran wins and
he's already failed in the UFC what's
the plan with him you're telling me he's
going to compete with the top 15.
they're not going to compete with these
Top Dogs on the flip side of that if you
look at it through the other side of
that exact same lens while on one hand
you're like okay but he already proved
that it's it's not going to pan out the
prospects how are they going to pan out
if they can't get through this series of
veterans if they can't get through these
guys then how are they going to fare in
the UFC it works both ways and
regardless the cream is going to rise to
the to the top I think whether it's a
vet or whether it's a prospect but I do
agree with you that there's an inherent
Advantage for the vets